hi I'm Jessica Clemons welcome back to
New rockstars Hallie is Alive and Well
in the latest trailer for The Little
Mermaid and I am shook I'm so proud of
my little baby she's not like my baby
but you get it she's come a long way
since grown-ish plus this trailer is
truly breathtaking and Disney heard all
of our requests and made flounder not as
scary as this one or this one so I'm
very excited for this live-action Little
Mermaid I love The Little Mermaid I
still love The Little Mermaid I'm a
Disney girl I'm a Disney adult whatever
label you want to give me who loves
Disney Princesses and cannot wait for
this one my dream has always been to be
a Disney princess and in some ways I am
Tiana either way the gang at new rock
stars let me reminisce about the best
part of my childhood with breaking down
this trailer so please let's take a trip
down memory lane together as I point out
the marvelous Easter eggs in remarkable
designs I can't shut up about I love The
Little Mermaid immediately first right
off the water fish fish right off the
fish I don't know this trailer hits the
same beats not necessarily in the exact
same order but of the original Little
Mermaid trailer that dropped in 88
there's some shots that are very
identical to the original movie which
we'll get into way down the line there's
a lot of different beats the trailer
opens so dark and gloomy honestly it's
like a little too dark I had to turn up
the brightness on my TV if you think
this was an episode of Ozark but instead
we're in the vast Atlantic Ocean I say
the Atlantic because Atlantica was
located beneath the Atlantic Ocean in
the first movie Plus in the teaser we
got some Atlantic ocean sea animals but
no reason they can't make up another
ocean is a Disney movie have fun there's
no room for logic and like the teaser
trailer it already shows how
breathtaking the movie will be Disney
really said do you remember that we have
National Geographic because baby I'll
never get over these visuals Prince
Eric's ship is out of control and the
waves are winning this mimics the scene
from the original movie where Prince
Eric and his men were caught in a
lightning storm their sail set ablazed
by lightning then they hit a giant rock
then the fire combined with the
gunpowder on the ship made it go boom we
only see the burning ship hit the rock
in the trailer but I think even though
it's raining what sets their ship Ablaze
are these hanging oil lamps that will
eventually hit the floor and be highly
flammable now the original Little
Mermaid came out in 89 when Disney love
put in their Sailors in this classic
19th century French sailor stripes in
this movie it looks like they're rep in
a more classic sailor look more English
all to say we'll be given a clearer live
action imagination to Disney's Little
Mermaid so historically or just to make
it look more defined and detailed we'll
see a lot of updates like how later we
see King Triton use a conch that wasn't
in the original movie but in mythology
he used one these minor things I'm sure
I will feed on because this job has
turned me into it analyzing lunatic
hence why I know enough about 19th
century sailor suits right as Prince
Eric collapses into the water almost
sinking into the ocean floor we get a
little hum from what I assume is area
it's the same Little tune she sings When
Ursula takes her voice in the original
movie sounds like this
and again like the original movie please
look at these frame by frame shots
because they're identical when Ariel
saves Eric from drowning once they've
breached the surface in the original
movie they're lit by the fireworks the
gunpowder explosion but in this trailer
they're lit by the nighttime sky and the
lightning we see the full moon later
which I assume is at the same time say
what you want about Disney Live actions
but they stick very close to the
original material we know our lovely
Aerials played by Halle Bailey a woman I
love dearly and her music is
I just love her I love her so much I
love them so much but Prince Eric is
played by Jonah Howard King Who played
Lori in the 2017 mini-series Little
Women he hasn't been in much but boy
snack and Prince Eric I mean Kudos
that's insane Ariel is startled and due
to the movie Magic it could easily be by
Max like it was in the first movie but
the editing in the trailer leads us to
believe it's Prince Eric's guards so we
don't know if there is a Max yet the man
leading the Brigade may be our Grimsby
Prince Eric's Guardian from the first
movie according to IMDb they've already
casted him as art Malik there's been
other casting announcements like Jessica
Alexander playing Vanessa whose Ursula
transform self Noma de Mosinee as Queen
Selena who I think will be Eric's mom in
a rumoring that lin-manuel Miranda would
be playing Chef Louie Lynn loves putting
himself in his projects I mean who
doesn't I do it and he will be creating
four new songs along with Alan Menken
who worked on the original score in the
80s we have a new and old Disney under
the same roof but I mean that's just
incredible to me it's the Disney 100
celebration and look at how beautiful
Cinderella's castle is it's gorgeous
plus the addition of the little Disney
nods like Matterhorn mountain and I
think that's Pride Rock is just insane
and really cute the circle made from the
Star Fades into the shape of the Cave's
mouth and I just love this transition
this is her little Hideaway of human
artifacts that we've seen in the first
movie we get a glimpse of our little
mermaid's tail and man the teal to
purple scales on this bad boy are
stunning I really like that they could
have gone the aquamarine route a
traditional fishtail but they have chose
the traditional mammal route instead she
literally has a dorsal and pelvic fin
she's made for swimming fast baby this
is a true mermaid watching something you
love is self-care feels good right well
with geology you can have that good
feeling of self-care in a daily routine
too geology is a 16 time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognizing Men's Health Esquire and ask
men grooming Awards with over 6 000 5
Star reviews I could never get that many
reviews just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs for Hair Care geology has
got some strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hair of your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products so you wash
your hair less and save more money and I
need money they also offer body washes
and deodorants that are fresh of harsh
ingredients and smell super great
for skin care they have you covered from
all angles fight acne reduce oiliness
that's me prevent wrinkles that's also
me combat darker puffy under eyes Okay
this seems very like about me have
smoother hydrated skin and Target signs
of aging oh my God these are all me
their daily personalized skincare
routines come with two face washes
morning face cream retinal night cream
and an eye cream and for right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only fifteen dollars if
you use code rockstar70 at checkout
that's over 50 of products for just
fifteen dollars
on top of that you'll get an additional
bonus offer on one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add it to your trial
just get started by clicking the link in
the description it's right below it's
over here go look at it now this scene
is probably from the worst scene in the
first movie it's where King Triton blows
up all of Ariel's belongings he hasn't
yet blown them up because that statue is
still intact assuming that's the Prince
Eric statue the one that he aims for
last we also get a good view of our baby
boy flounder who's voiced by Jacob
Tremblay and we get a little yell of his
voice later in the trailer and before
y'all get mad at this fish's appearance
it is literally a tropical fish if he is
an angelfish they didn't even do that
bad of a job sometimes animation you got
to make things look a little more like
you don't deny it because I know you
wouldn't love that cockroach and Wally
if it was a real freaking cockroach King
Triton is played by none other than
Javier bardev who needs no introduction
but my favorite film of his is No
Country for Old Men We Know King Triton
has seven daughters in the original film
Athena Alana Adela aquata Arista Adrina
and Ariel but according to IMDb Simone
Ashley from Bridgeton will be playing
Endura one of Ariel's sisters in an
interview with Teen Vogue there's a new
book by New York Times bestseller JL
inspired by the new film called against
the type where it confirms the daughters
indura Mala Karina caspia Perla and
Tamika Crossing that with the IMDb some
have already been cast so the names of
the sisters have changed but I think
most of their names reflect them
culturally Simone Ashley is British with
South Asian descent and her character
Indra means Beauty and Splendid in Hindu
Lorena adrea is Colombian her character
is Perla meaning Pearl we get an outside
view of Ursula's Manor and in the
original film as a child I was always
confused whether this was a giant
skeleton or a cave but it looked like a
cave and the entrance was a mouth of a
giant fish which in this movie it's
still a giant fish mouth entrance the
inside of the cave doorway in the first
movie had all the seaweed people trapped
and loose tendrils but in this movie
it's just straight up skull and it makes
me love Ursula even more she's a great
villain she also resides in a hanging
sword a conch in the first movie or a
shell but I like it being a giant
metallic clam with a pearl inside in
this movie this could be for logic or
practicality it just might be easier to
get out of an open Shell versus a conch
and as we already knew urzla is played
by Melissa McCarthy and I have no hate
towards her I'm excited to see her take
it on I would have put maybe someone
like Nina West but Melissa May steal our
hearts she'll have some big shoes to
fill or tentacles whatever works that's
when we're brought onto Shore Ariel
she's legged and scuttled voiced by
Aquafina this Scuttle got a full upgrade
and those eyes are truly lifeless
Scuttle was a dummy seagull in the first
movie but now as a female diving bird so
we can see her underwater at times
speaking of lifeless eyes we get our
actual crab like crab Sebastian who's
voiced by David Diggs and baby this is
when it pops off this is when I pop off
because we know an Ali rail is perched
behind that rock hiding from Prince
Eric's guards what's about to happen
what's she singing and how I'm gonna
sing it with her what I assume is the
POV of another mermaid this could be
their way to the underwater Kingdom and
the first move movie at the very
beginning the mermaids made their way to
the kingdom to watch The Seven Daughters
perform it could be the homes because
later in the trailer we see King
Triton's daughters and the background
are the same Rock sculptures then we
jump to what I think are tidbits of the
classic song Under the Sea where all the
sea creatures are gathered around Ariel
to tell her how great it is to stay in
the ocean I think this bit and this part
and this part are all part of the Under
the Sea song we jump to Prince Eric and
Ariel on a carriage she's wearing the
outfit she's wearing later during the
Kiss the Girls scene then we get a shot
of King Triton's daughters and it's so
quick you can barely make them out and
there's only five there instead of the
full seven and the sort of close-up I
think is caspia Natalie Sorel to the
left is Sienna King's Tamika now I can
barely make out the rest of the girls
but as a note the other sisters are and
I'm so sorry because I know I'm
butchering this name kaisa momar as
Karina and Carolina conch as Mala
though they don't start with A's like in
the first movie they all end with Oz
like Jessica everyone but Ariel of
course the song Part of Your World is
playing as we Montage through the
trailer and by God we got it we get the
infamous Rock scene but we we all do
when we're at the beach and there's a
boulder nearby and if you forgot what
this movie is about King trying reminds
us by saying he's a human you're a
mermaid an area responds that doesn't
make us enemies which we know is during
the daddy I love him part in the First
movie and I just love that sound bite so
please play it again
perfect we got a gander at a door you
can Finding Nemo also I'm sure we'll see
a lot of fish from Finding Nemo because
why not allow the mini crossover
additionally we gotta look at the
undersea ship and I assume this is the
inside of the ship where she finds the
dingle hopper the fork in the first
movie I love Disney Princess movies and
I hope you do too if you see in this
just for Hallie that's also okay I'm so
excited for the soundtrack you don't
even know follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
and what's the word oh yeah bye
[Music]
foreign